hagamos algunos ejercicios de nuestro
módulo 1 de probabilidad por ejemplo
tenemos una bolsa con 9 canicas rojas 2
canicas azules y 3 canicas verdes cuál
es la probabilidad de que al elegir
aleatoriamente una canica ésta no sea
azul dibujemos la bolsa con canicas
vamos a dibujar una bolsa más o menos
así dibujamos primero las canicas rojas
son 9 canicas rojas 123456789 canicas
rojas ahora son 2 canicas azules 1 2 y
finalmente 3 canicas verdes 1 2 3
lo que tenemos que pensar es cuál
fracción del total de eventos posibles
cumple con nuestras restricciones
pensemos primero en todos los eventos
posibles todos los eventos posibles
cuántas canicas diferentes podemos sacar
pues el número total de canicas que
tenemos que son 9 + 2 11 + 3 14 tenemos
14 canicas sume estas cantidades o
también pude haberlas contado este es el
número de posibilidades número de
posibilidades
y luego tenemos que ver qué fracción de
dichas posibilidades cumplen con
nuestras restricciones en este caso que
al elegir una canica ésta no sea azul
otra forma de verlo es que sea una
canica roja o verde pues son los colores
diferentes del azul así que cuántas
canicas no azules hay bueno tenemos
nueve canicas rojas y tres canicas
verdes van a ser un total de 12 canicas
que no son azules 12 canicas no azules
estas son las posibilidades que cumplen
con nuestras restricciones y abajo
tenemos todas las posibilidades vamos a
simplificar esta fracción podemos
dividir el numerador y el denominador
entre 2 y nos va a quedar que esto es
igual a 2 entre 2 614 entre 2 7-6
séptimos es la probabilidad de obtener
una canica no azul de esta bolsa de
canicas hagamos otro problema si un
número de la siguiente lista se elige
aleatoriamente cuál es la probabilidad
de que este número sea un múltiplo de 5
nuevamente queremos encontrar qué
fracción de todas nuestras posibilidades
cumplen con las restricciones que en
este caso es que el número sea múltiplo
de 5 cuál es el total de nuestras
posibilidades aquí va total
posibilidades pues vamos a contar todos
los números que tenemos tenemos 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 12 12 posibilidades y
de estos cuales son múltiplos de 5 vamos
a buscar aquellos números en cuya unidad
haya un 0 o un 5 32 no cumple 49 55 si
lo cumple 30 también lo cumple 56 9 28
en los 50 así 40 también pues este es
otro 40 así que también lo cumple 45 si
lo cumple 3 no y 25 si tenemos uno dos
tres cuatro cinco seis siete números que
cumplen con nuestras restricciones siete
números que cumplen con las
restricciones en este ejemplo vemos que
la probabilidad de elegir un número
aleatoriamente de todos estos y que sea
múltiplo de cinco es de 712 a 2
hagamos otro problema la circunferencia
de un círculo es de 36 pin contenido en
dicho círculo hay un círculo más pequeño
que tiene un área de 16 bits si se elige
un punto al azar dentro del círculo
grande cuál es la probabilidad de que
este punto también se encuentre dentro
del círculo pequeño dibujemos nuestro
círculo y de este nos dicen que su
circunferencia circunferencia es de 36
pi y luego nos dicen que hay un círculo
adentro más pequeño y de este círculo
nos dicen que el área es de 16 pi su
área es de 16 pi algo interesante de
mencionar es que existen infinidad de
puntos en ambos círculos no tenemos
elementos individuales como las canicas
del ejercicio del inicio hay un número
infinito de puntos aquí así que lo que
nos piden en el problema es qué
porcentaje de los puntos en el círculo
grande también se encuentran en el
círculo pequeño otra forma de verlo es
que el porcentaje del círculo grande
se encuentra en el círculo pequeño puede
serles confuso pero lo que tenemos que
hacer es comparar las proporciones de
las áreas de los círculos podemos verlos
tentados a usar este 36 pib pero
recordemos que esta es la circunferencia
y lo que tenemos que comparar son las
áreas de ambos círculos para calcular el
área necesitamos conocer el radio porque
el área espí por radio al cuadrado y lo
podemos inferir con los datos que nos
dan nos dicen que la circunferencia se
es igual a 2 pi por radio nos dan el
valor de la circunferencia que es 36 pi
36 pi es igual a 2 pi por radio para
despejar el radio que es lo que nos
interesa dividimos todo entre 2 pin
dividimos esto entre 2 pin y aquí
también 2 pin esto se va step y se va 36
entre 2 es 18 esto es 18 y nos queda que
el radio es igual a 18 ahora sí con este
dato podemos calcular el área del
círculo grande tenemos que el radio de
este círculo grande
es 18 nuestra fórmula del área es igual
a pi por radio al cuadrado que es igual
a ti
el radio de 1818 al cuadrado y vamos a
ver 18 por 18 cuánto es 8 por 8 64 llevo
68 por 18 6 son 14 1 por 18 es 18 aquí
dejamos un 0 porque estamos
multiplicando con las decenas sumamos 42
si llevamos 13 324 el área del círculo
grande es igual a 324 pi
así que la probabilidad la probabilidad
de que este punto también se encuentre
dentro del círculo pequeño todo esto
esta probabilidad de aquí es igual a el
área del círculo pequeño 16 pi entre el
área del círculo grande 324 bien estás
pic se van dividimos numerador y
denominador entre 4 para simplificarlo
nos queda y si se es entre 434 y aquí
abajo nos queda 81 y vemos que realmente
no dibuje los círculos a escala el
círculo de dentro es mucho más pequeño y
la probabilidad que nos piden es la
proporción del área pequeña con respecto
al área grande y es 4 a 81